In this exercise, we're going to try to make the petals look better. Starting
with your solution to the previous problem, make two small changes that will
make the petals look more realistic. The first is to squish the petals, make
them one quarter as tall as they were before. The second is to tilt the petals
up by 20 degrees. When you're done you should get something like this, which
looks at least a little bit more like a flower. Notice that all of the points of
the petals should still be at the center of the stamen, the sphere at the top of
the stem. When I first solved this problem, my petals were pointing below the
stamen, which isn't what I wanted. I expect that you can do better than I first
did.